so as we're getting closer and closer to
vaccine approval
in the united states which could come as
soon as
thursday or friday of this week or over
the weekend
there are more and more explosive
disagreements about
what needs to be done right now in terms
of the virus and there was a
conversation about this that completely
exploded on cnbc a few days ago
now for context if you've been following
the
absolutely horrifying numbers cases in
the united states
have gone off the charts we've had as
many as 200
000 cases per day recently
and it's not just cases that have been
increasing
deaths have also exploded and now
looking like we could have really a
sustained period
of 3 000 deaths per day for some time
that's essentially
a 9 11's worth of deaths every single
day now assuming the vaccine is shortly
approved
it's going to be a relatively slow
rollout
if you look optimistically we would have
the capacity to vaccinate maybe six to
eight percent of the population per
month
maybe more if we get a second vaccine
maybe even a third
vaccine approved and starting to be
supplied so the point is
no matter what the next three months are
going to be a time where we have to be
really really careful so on cnbc
anchor andrew ross sorkin who has mostly
been in favor of just
following what experts say it's not he's
coming up with this stuff he's mostly
been saying
here's what the medical experts are
saying he was on an interview panel
with correspondent rick santelli and
rick santelli has been wildly out of
control
loudly and defiantly ridiculing and
ignoring
varieties of guidelines and the
situation escalated really quickly let's
take a look
yes no i believe me i believe in careful
and when i point out
governor's cheating it's not for the
hypocrisy which exists
it's the fact that i think many of these
governors are intelligent people
and they love their families which
they've taken out into restaurants
therefore there is actually and should
be an ongoing debate
as to you know why a parking lot for a
big box store
like by my house is jam-packed not one
parking spot open
why are those people any safer than a
restaurant with plexiglass
i i just don't get it and i think
there's a million of these questions
that could be asked
and i think it's really sad that when we
look at the service sector and all the
discussions we've had about job losses
that that particular dynamic isn't
studied more
is it worked more we don't put more
people in a room and try to figure out
ways
so that these service sector employees
and employers
could all come back in a safer way you
can't
tell me that shutting down which is the
easiest answer
is necessarily the only answer so
now here so far although rick and i
could
could do would come to different
conclusions i don't disagree with rick
about what he's saying
there are many guidelines particularly
when you look between states but also
within
states that aren't coherent he says
why is it safe to jam-pack a big box
store
but a small restaurant can't be open
that's a great question and in fact
it doesn't appear to be safe to pack the
big box store in many states where
people aren't wearing masks especially
big box stores are exactly where a lot
of the contagion is happening
rick is inadvertently getting to an
important point which is
it's not that open all restaurants it's
the big box stores aren't actually safe
back in early november officials in el
paso texas found
a huge number of cases were being
transmitted at
big box stores in el paso including
walmart target home depot and lowe's
so the problem is rick saying open
everything because the big box stores
are open it seems really what we need is
the big box stores need to dramatically
reduce capacity
so then andrew ross sorkin jumps in and
this gets ugly pretty quickly
rick i just i just as a as a as a public
health and public service announcement
uh for the audience
the difference between a big box
retailer what is this hold on the
difference between it
the different the difference between a
big box retailer
hold on the difference between a big box
retailer
and a restaurant or frankly even a a
church are so different it's
unbelievable
going into the big box retailer i
disagree
500 people at a lowe's aren't any safer
than 150 people in a restaurant that
holds 600
i don't believe it sorry don't believe
me okay
and i live in an area where there's a
lot of restaurants that have fought back
and they don't have any problems
and they're open okay you don't have to
believe it but let me just say this
you're doing a disservice to the viewer
because the viewers need to understand
the difference
you are you are
i i'm sorry i'm sorry if
i i would like to keep our viewers as
healthy as humanly possible
the idea of packing people into
restaurants i think our viewers are
smart enough to make part of those
decisions
so it quickly became no you are but what
am i
um and now rick actually says something
interesting
our viewers are smart enough to decide
on their own
that is just not true i i hate it that
it's not true
check out my video viral video from what
was it a year or so ago
uh we have to accept that a lot of
people are stupid have you seen the
trump rallies where
rally-goers are asked why aren't you
wearing a mask and the answers range
from the virus doesn't exist it's a fake
news conspiracy
masks do nothing i'm protected by jesus
because i prayed
the problem is you need the guidelines
to be stricter than what most people
would need
because there's people that will
disregard them completely
you say outdoor is fine without masks as
was said earlier in the pandemic
then you see hundreds of people packing
narrow hiking trails in california
they've found the one way to make
outdoor
not safe so now you need to say well you
need masks outdoors as well you got to
close the hiking trails
people aren't smart enough that's an
unfortunate thing let's see the last bit
of this
i don't think that i'm much smarter than
all the viewers like some people do
can i get in here please and get back to
the job support how's that working out
for you rick
how's it all working out for you i mean
look at the numbers rick it's working
out fine i think
the numbers rick the lie rick rick the
numbers show that the idea is
it's a horrible fall and people are
getting sick and dying
i just think the way we deal with this
isn't
so of course the way we've dealt with
this
hasn't been optimal that's absolutely
true
no coordinated federal response going
back 10 months now
um disinformation coming out of the
white house the white house a vector of
disinformation
replacing you know we could pick
anything replacing dr anthony fauci
with a radiologist for months as donald
trump did
um suggesting maybe you inject bleach
and hit the body with the disinfectant
but part of the reason we need to be
fighting uphill
is because of people like uh like rick
santelli so
i i think that um listen i've said
before
you look at states with high and low
mass usage at least on paper
and sometimes you don't see dramatic
differences in contagion what explains
that well you've got to dig deeper
maybe the state with the high mask usage
on paper people are having more indoor
gatherings because it's a cold state
and so you don't have people abiding by
only hanging out outdoors
i get that there are still many
questions we don't understand
you look at latin american countries on
paper some of the strictest
guidelines and and even actual lockdowns
and they have some
incredible rates of contagion well when
you dig into it you realize
on paper the guidelines are strict
nobody's abiding by them
i get it but we can't pretend
that the problem is merely that all of
the scientists
are wrong and have no idea what's going
on it's absolutely ridiculous and that
escalated very very quickly